depuis un an les rires et les cris des
enfants ne raisonnent plus dans cette
cour de récréation l'école est fermée
pour les élèves comme plus de 30% des
établissements dans le pays
seuls certains enseignants viennent ici
pour donner leur cours en ligne Irina et
professeur d'informatique ce jour-là 10
élèves sont devant leurs écrans certains
vivent en Ukraine d'autres ont fui à
l'étranger à peine la leçon débuter elle
est interrompue rattrapée par la réalité
de la guerre
les enfants nous avons une alerte
entière s'il vous plaît écoutez-moi
à ceux qui se trouvent en dehors du pays
à ceux pour qu'il n'y a pas d'alarme
restez où vous êtes
si dans votre ville il y a une alerte
entière veuillez vous mettre à l'abri
dans un endroit sûr c'est compris
de cette façon mais les cours en ligne
on leur limite
c'est compliqué de donner des cours en
ligne je ne vois pas mes élèves
directement donc je ne les connais pas
bien je ne sais pas ce qu'ils font de
leur vie ou ce qui les intéressent et je
ne peux donc pas utiliser ces
informations lorsque j'enseigne
être seul devant un ordinateur pose
aussi des problèmes aux élèves surtout
pour les plus jeunes
en tant que il n'y a pas d'interaction
entre les élèves et c'est très visible
ils sont enfermés chez eux les enfants
de cette génération n'ont pas vraiment
d'amis parce que l'école a été fermé à
cause du covid et maintenant l'école est
encore fermée à cause de la guerre
d'achat à 10 ans elle est en dernière
année d'école primaire une année passée
à la maison avec ses parents ses amis et
son école lui manque
j'aime bien les cours en ligne mais ce
n'est pas comme dans la vraie vie c'est
très difficile de faire ses devoirs
parce qu'on peut vite être distrait par
autre chose quand on étudie
comme tous les élèves elle a dû tant
bien que mal s'adapter
d'ailleurs je vais vous dire je connais
le nom des élèves et à travers ses cours
en ligne je vois qu'ils sont tous très
gentils j'aimerais être ami avec eux
son souhait le plus cher que sa
prochaine rentrée scolaire se fasse dans
son école